Venice Italy already dealing with a
catastrophic flooding is bracing for
high tide today that could reach nearly
twice the normal level and that's very
bad news for a city facing the second
worst flooding in nearly a hundred years
at least two people have died there and
this morning the city's mayor is closed
historic st. Mark's Square Holly
Williams is in Venice with more on this
story
Holly good morning to you good morning
well if you want a sense of the
devastation that these floods have
caused in Venice this is probably the
best place to start sent Mark's Basilica
which is the historic and spiritual
heart of Venice this structure dates
back nearly a thousand years and for the
second time this week it is under water
we are in the the crit in the basement
of the church it's already caused
millions of dollars of damage this week
but it's not about the money because
many of these bricks and the marble here
are simply irreplaceable
they are centuries old this is
heartbreaking for the people of Venice
we've been walking around the streets of
Venice this morning or to be more
accurate waiting because in parts of the
city
the water is waist high that Venice
floods dozens of times every year but
this is highly unusual and many people
here fear that it is becoming the new
normal the mayor of Venice has blamed
climate change for this disaster and
many local residents tell us that they
agree Tony
Polly Williams in Venice Forest Holly
thank you very much you might need to
get higher boots there tell that story